[Music]
that's cristian serrados playing selena
quintanilla
in selena the series in the first
trailer fans watched the queen of tejano
music's rise to superstardom
starting with the early years when
selena's family first noticed her talent
that's why i'm living it it feels like
there's a
fist around your heart well i don't want
that
we see selena on the road playing gigs
and recording music
are you guys ready to stop
[Applause]
[Music]
and a glimpse into the love story with
her guitarist turned husband chris perez
i can't like him i mean it that would
freak out
[Music]
she was very silly right yeah in a good
way but she could be serious
she could be serious too you didn't want
to get on her bad side but you know love
her either way
better grab your tissues you're gonna
need them for all the heartfelt family
moments
we might really need a different drummer
there's
no beatles without ringo and there's no
selena without susan
when i think about being on stage when
you on base and susan on the drums
nothing else matters
the show which is co-executive produced
by selena's sister suzette and father
abraham
will drop december 4th on netflix
it marks the first tv series to
chronicle the late singer's life and
musical journey
and comes over two decades after the
1997 biopic
starring jennifer lopez
[Music]
excited as an actress getting into who
she was
as a person learning her character
getting into that character taught me so
much about life
i honestly believe it was god sent me
that role
for a reason so i could learn from her
so i could always have her as an
inspiration and somebody to look to in
my life
to guide me on how to navigate this
business and
how to be and just it was a great lesson
to know that
you know you're not promised tomorrow
and you have to you have to love and
live for today
in 2017 the selena movie turned 20
and e.t exclusively sat down with the
quintanillas to pay
tribute to her life and legacy
how do you want her to be remembered as
a
given person sweet personality
happy she was always happy
and really that's exactly how people see
her
she's being remembered the way she needs
to be remembered
you